members we are back on live screen
streaming could I ask all those members
who would like a recorded vote to
indicate by their raised hands please
I'm sorry chairman let's throw in the
coordinates we've got a point of order
that's no in accordance with the
Constitution it's not in accordance with
the notes given to us which we abide by
earlier and there's no debate there's
normally a debate on whether things
going to exempt or not are we not
allowed to have that debate either now
what other point chairman if I may I
raised my hand as I can see did about
eight or nine of us thinking that we
were going to have a debate after the
presentations have been made and we're
just getting our hands in there early so
you're looking at screen you can see it
about seven or eight hands already
raised so that needs to be counseled
first
members there'll be a full debate after
the presentation from Matt Harvard white
and miss Lucas but for now I'm just
going to doing a roll call vote for
those who wish to have a recorded vote
so on a point builder aren't we having
the exclusion of public and press read
out to us to know what we're voting on
that would be normal procedures in any
meeting well if you allow me two seconds
I will do that recorded vote is to
whether we go in to exempt okay that's
what the vote is for it can you please
I'll come back to you members
members we are voting now on whether the
press and public be excluded from the
meeting for the remaining business on
the grounds that exempt information in
as defined in paragraph 3 of part 1 of
schedule 12a of the Local Government Act
1972 would be disclosed members I shall
now take her vote on that as to whether
you wish to have a recorded vote please
answer yes or no when I call your name
councillor Burton
sorry counts a Belton my apologies but
be clear chairman is this just but if I
want it recorded vote
no Burton no counselor mrs. butcher no
no counselor mrs. Carter now it's the
mrs. Carter can you hear me mr. chairman
I've been trying to advise you for some
time but you've acknowledged our hands
lost signal and he's trying to reconnect
I shall come back to her myself
no counselor ft no as it's already
recorded councillor Eve's
sorry I didn't hear that count leaves no
you don't want to record it vote yeah
yeah it's the Gooding now it's the
Hazelwood no now's the hook way
no boy yes counselor Hudson no counselor
I oh no no now it's a Lucas Gil no
counselor mrs. Lumley
no mrs. Mason yes counselor mrs.
Macpherson counselor Mirek South
American here Thank You mr. counselor
Marik causa Milne no counsel Newport yes
counselor mrs. Paley counselor mrs.
Brown no it's already recording yes the
mrs. Shaw sorry on a point of order
please chairman can we ask these people
to stop saying it is being recorded a
recorded vote is different to a vote to
be folded cancellous I've already asked
you not to speak until I can see you can
could you please not speak until I tell
you that you can speak Lee Thank You
counselor short counselor mr. Shaw no
Joseph Smith no counts of sparing no
Elsa Stanley yes yeah it's a Steptoe yes
the web no the Western no Council will
Kingson no Counsell Williams counsel
Wilson
yes council wooden members there'll be
no recorded vote come on yourselves for
point of clarification mr. chairman
again to a roll call vote as to whether
we go into P and C when I call your name
could you please indicate yes or no or
abstain please counselor mrs. Felton yes
counselor Burton yes counselor mr. wood
shop yes yes counselor mrs. Kyle I'll
come back to you that's right yes
counselor FT yes counselor Eve's yes
counselor Gooding yes counselor
Hazelwood yes yes counselor mr. Hoya no
and always my vote recorded against
Thank You counselor Hudson yes counselor
I Onew yes Lucas Gil yes counselor mrs.
Lumley yes counselor mrs. Mason
no no sir mrs. Macpherson yes counselor
Marik
Johnson Bjorn
yes now it's a Newport no and please
record my vote in the minutes counselor
mrs. Palin
yes mrs. Ron yes mrs. Shaw yes mr. Shaw
yes accounts are Smith yes coughs
whispering yes
no sir Stanley please that's a step toe
yes now the ward yes counselor Webb yes
now's the Western Council wilkinson
yes Counsell Williams yes counselor
Wilson no could I have my vote record in
the minutes please chair counsel wooden
yes
Thank You members we will go in to say
and I just I haven't haven't really been
in the meeting because I lost the signal
chairman and can I just vote on that as
a no and I'd like mine recorded as well
please that's noted mrs. Krakauer mrs.
Carter